SPACE IS AN INTERESTING THING.
IT'S AN UNKNOWN.
IT'S A FRONTIER.
I THINK THE BIG MYSTERY TO ME
IS FINDING OTHER LIFE
IN THE UNIVERSE.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS LIFE OUT THERE.
IN FACT, I BELIEVE
THERE'S A LOT OF LIFE
OUT IN THE UNIVERSE.
THE UNIVERSE,
FOR ALL INTENTS AND PURPOSES,
IS INFINITE.
AND SO IT'D BE
THE HEIGHT OF ARROGANCE
TO THINK THAT WE
HERE ON THE EARTH
ARE THE ONLY LIFE IN THIS
BASICALLY INFINITE UNIVERSE.
WHEN YOU DO THE MATH,
YOU CAN SAY,
"THERE ARE PROBABLY
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF PLANETS
THAT CAN SUPPORT LIFE."
THE PARADOX IS,
IF YOU HAVE THAT MANY PLANETS
THAT CAN SUPPORT LIFE
IN A UNIVERSE,
WHERE ARE ALL THE ALIENS?
Bean: PART OF EXPLORATION IS
HOPING YOU SEE SOMETHING
THAT YOU DIDN'T EXPECT.
I CAN REMEMBER WALKING AROUND
ON THE MOON
WISHING I COULD LOOK DOWN
AND SEE AN ARROWHEAD
OR SOMETHING THAT WOULD SAY
"ANCIENT CIVILIZATION WAS HERE."
THE DISTANCES ARE SO VAST
THAT WE MAY NEVER FIND
EACH OTHER.
WE MAY BE HUNDREDS OR EVEN MORE
MILLIONS OF LIGHT-YEARS APART.
AND SO THE IDEA THAT
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO FIND
SOME SIGNAL OR SOME INDICATION
THAT THERE IS OTHER LIFE
OUT THERE...